PROFESSOR: So I want to begin
today by continuing at the
point where we left off the
in the previous lecture.
Which was to talk about, in the
context of Jonathan Shay's
work, Achilles In Vietnam, the
costs that seem to arise when
people find themselves through
circumstance engaging in
behavior that they, on
reflection, believe to be
immoral or unjust.
So in 1961, in newspapers
throughout the New Haven area,
the following advertisement
appeared.
It said, "Public announcement.
We will pay you $4"--
that was quite a bit of money
at that time-- "$4 for one
hour of your time.
Persons needed for
study of memory.
We will pay $500 New Haven
men to help us complete a
scientific study of memory
and learning.
The study is being done
at Yale University.
Each person who participates
will be will be paid $4, plus
$0.50 in carfare, for
approximately one hour's time.
We need you only for
that one hour.
There no further obligations.
You may choose the time that
you would like to come,
evenings, and weekends, or
weekdays." And then the ad
continued by saying that "no
special training, education,
or experience was needed,"
that they wanted "factory
workers, city employees,
laborers, barbers,
businessmen, clerks,
professional people, telephone
workers, construction workers,
salespeople, white collar
workers, and others."
So when people answered this
advertisement, they were
invited to come to a building
whose exterior should be
familiar to you.
The building was
Linsley-Chittenden Hall.
And when they walked into that
building, they encountered the
study of a gentleman who
looked like this.
The advertisement that I've just
shown you is, of course,
the advertisement recruiting
subject to participate in the
famous Milgram study.
So the participants filled out
the coupon at the bottom of
the ad and came to laboratory
in what is now
Linsley-Chittenden Hall.
The configuration of the
building was different then,
but the facade was grand,
and the lab was elegant.
When subjects entered the lab,
they were told that they would
be participating in a study of
learning and memory, and they
were told that there were two
roles that they might play.
They might be the teacher, or
they might be the learner.
But as a matter of fact, when
they drew the folded pieces of
paper, both of them said
"teacher," and the other
subject, who was apparently
participating in this study,
was in fact the collaborator.
So when the study was actually
carried out, the people who
played the role of teacher were
forty men from the New
Haven area who had responded to
these ads who ranged in age
from twenty to fifty, who had
a wide range of occupations
and education levels.
And all of them were told that
that they were going to engage
in a task that involved testing
the role of punishment
on learning, and they were
told that the second
character, the learner, who
was a forty seven year old
accountant of Irish-American
stock whom almost all of them
described as mild-mannered and
likeable, would be presented
with a series of pairs of words,
and that their task
would simply be to provide him
with an electric shock every
time he got the answer wrong.
And in order to supervise the
study as it went on, there was
a third person present--
the experimenter--
who was a stern, impassive
thirty one year old high
school biology teacher.
So in every single one of the
cases, two of the figures, the
experimenter and the learner,
were the same, and one of the
figures, the teacher, varied.
The task was as follows.
They were presented with a
machine that had on it a
series of switches that began
with the label "slight shock,"
15 volt, 30 volt, 45 volt,
60 volt, and continued in
increments of 15, 75, 90, 105,
120, et cetera, all the way
through "intense shock" : 255,
270, 285, 300, "danger severe
shock," and finally, (don't
search for this on Google!)
"XXX."
So they were each given in a
shock, purportedly by the
machine, of 45 volts,
which most of them
estimated to be 70 volts.
That is, they felt it
quite intensely.
And then they were told that
they would need to administer
a shock to the learner every
time he made a mistake.
Now, before Milgram conducted
this study, he surveyed a
bunch of Yale senior psychology
majors who make
predictions about how many
shocks the teachers would be
willing to give.
And if you can see from this
graph, that prediction was
that no more than 3% of subjects
would give shocks at
the level 20, which is down at
the level of danger, and that
virtually no one would go
to the highest level.
What happened instead, all of
you know, with respect to the
slight shocks (15, 30,
45, 60), 100% of the
teachers gave them.
With respect to the intense
shocks (255, 270, 285, 300),
88% of the subjects
went there.
When they expressed
dissatisfaction at continuing,
they were told by the
experimenter, "Please
continue," or "The experiment
requires that you continue" or
"It is absolutely essential that
you continue," or "You
have no other choice, you must
go on," but no other
encouragement was provided.
Nonetheless, up to the level of
"danger, severe shock," 68%
of the subjects continued, and
all the way up to the very
last level, 65% continued.
This much is frequently
emphasized when people discuss
the Milgram experiment, and its
extraordinary fact about
human beings that Milgram was
prompted to investigate
because, of course, this
possibility had just been
demonstrated profoundly for
the world outside of the
laboratory.
The research that Milgram
conducted was inspired by an
attempt to understand what could
possibly have explained
the behavior of ordinary German
citizens in Nazi Germany.
That said, what I want to bring
out about the Milgram
study is in fact the part of
the discussion that comes
subsequent to what I've
just presented.
Which is the discussion
of what it felt like,
subjectively, to these subjects,
when they felt
themselves to be perpetrating
painful behavior on another.
As, as you can see from this
slide, so many of them did.
The psychological response of
the subjects sounds like what
we read in Jonathan Shay's book
for the last lecture.
Many subjects showed "signs of
nervousness, especially upon
administering the more
powerful shock.
In a large number of cases, the
degree of tension reached
extremes rarely seen in such
laboratory subjects.
They were observed to sweat,
to stutter, to bite their
lips, to groan, to dig their
fingernails into their flesh."
These were characteristic
rather
than exceptional responses.
And if you've never seen the
film that Milgram made in
conducting the experiments--
which are not public domain,
but I here just give you
information about something
that's on the Iinternet--
you can listen to the
experimenter's calm voice, and
watch the subjects' agitation.
Here's a description.
"One might suppose," says
Milgram, reporting "that a
subject would simply break
off, or continue as his
conscience dictated.
Yet this is far from
what happened.
There were striking reactions
of tension
and emotional strain.
One observer related, 'I
observed a mature and
initially poised businessman
enter the laboratory, smiling
and confident.
Within twenty minutes, he was
reduced to a twitching,
stuttering wreck.
He constantly pulled
on his earlobe.
He twisted his hands.
At one point, he pushed his fist
into his forehead, and
muttered, "Oh God, let's stop
it," and yet, and yet he
continued to respond to every
word of the experimenter, and
obeyed to the end.'"
So it's a funny thing about
we human creatures.
That on the one hand, we seem to
have a sense of what we can
comfortably put up with.
And we have, on the contrary, an
ability to go beyond that.
That capacity can be exploited
for the good or for the bad.
Those of you who are on sports
teams know the experience of
being pushed past what you
thought could possibly be your
limit, and finding yourself
carrying through, despite the
fact that initially it seems
like something impossible.
But it's always the case that
things with which we feel
repulsion are things
that we may find
ourselves carrying out.
Nonetheless, that carries
with it psychic costs.
And that's the second answer
that I want to give in the
context of the lecture on themis
to Glaucon's challenge.
I want to turn now to the topic
of today's lecture,
flourishing and attachment, by
actually continuing with a
variation on the Milgram
studies.
Because after Milgram found
these results through the 1961
work, he was gripped by the
question, under what
circumstances was compliance
more or less likely?
So in a follow-up study done
the next year, Milgram
explored the question in its
most general form, as follows.
In its most general form, the
problem is this: "if X tells Y
to hurt Z, under what conditions
will Y carry out
the command of X,
and under what
conditions will he refuse?
In the more limited form
possible in laboratory
research, the question becomes:
if an experimenter
tells a subject to hurt another
person, under what
conditions will the subject go
along with this instruction,
and under what conditions
will he refuse to obey?"
Milgram set out to test this by
varying along a continuum
the degree of human interaction
in the study.
So in one series of studies,
the experimenter, the one
telling you to continue, was
either in the room with you,
or on the phone with you, or
such that you only received
written instructions.
And the tendency of subject to
collaborate, to cooperate, to
do what was act of them,
declined directly with whether
the experimenter was present
in the room with them.
Likewise, Milgram varied the
extent to which the subject
received feedback from the
person being shocked.
Did they receive no feedback,
called the remote condition?
Did they receive the sort of
voice feedback, as in the
initial experiments, where you'd
hear the person shouting
through the wall, "It's
painful, I'm
hurting, please stop"?
Were they in the room with the
subject, observing him suffer,
or did they finally, in the most
extreme condition, need
to take the subject's arm, put
it onto a metal plate, and
hold the there in order
to give him a shock?
What Milgram discovered is that
although compliance is
extremely high when there's no
feedback from the sufferer,
it's lower when there's voice
feedback, lower still when
you're in the room with the
person you're harming, and
lower still when you yourself
need to use your
body to cause harm.
You'll recall in the very
first lecture, the
introductory lecture, when I was
telling you about one of
the questions we would
discuss this term.
That I presented you with
something called the trolley
problem, a case where a trolley
is hurtling down a
track, and it's headed
towards five people.
And in the first version of
that study, I asked you
whether it would be morally
acceptable to divert the
trolley in such a way that it
went onto a track where there
was only one person, and
most of you thought
that was all right.
In the second variation of the
study, I asked you whether it
would be OK to stop the trolley
by pushing into the
track of a trolley a fat man who
was standing next to you
on a bridge overlooking
the tracks.
And most of you thought
that was not OK.
There's something in the human
perception of our interactions
with one another that seems to
give rise to anxiety in the
face of caused harms whose
consequences we see.
Milgram articulates it thus.
He says, "In the remote, and to
a lesser extent, the voice
feedback condition, the victim
suffering possesses an
abstract, remote quality
for the subject.
He's aware, but only in a
conceptual sense." His reason
knows, in Plato's terminology,
but the other parts of his
soul haven't registered
what's going on.
"This phenomenon," Milgram
continues, "is common enough.
The bombardier can reasonably
suppose that his weapons will
inflict suffering and death.
In fact, they do just as good
a job killing people as
bayonets do.
But this knowledge is divested
of affect, and does not move
him to a felt emotional response
to the sufferings of
his actions."
Similar observations had
been made in wartime.
Visual cues associated with the
victim's suffering trigger
empathic responses in the
subject and provide him with a
more complete grasp of the
victim's experience.
And it turns out that one of the
major strategies in Nazi
Germany to enable people to
commit harm against their
neighbors was to use a language
of dehumanization
that referred to groups being
harmed--the Jews, the gypsies,
the homosexuals--as non-human
in some way.
When we perceive another as
human, it is difficult to
overcome the tendency not
to want to harm them.
And though I've given you a
number of examples of the way
in which military resistance
can be a powerful mechanism
for pursuing one's will, this
fact that Milgram observes is
actually what underlies the
possibility of another form of
resistance which has
been, in some
circumstances, shockingly effective.
Here's Gandhi, engaging in
nonviolent protests in India
in the 1940s.
Here's a sit-in at the
lunch counters in
Selma, Alabama in 1963.
And here, of course, is one of
the most famous pictures of
the last two decades.
An individual standing alone
before tanks in a way that
causes them to halt their motion
in Tiananmen Square.
So what is it in about human
beings that makes it easier
for us to avoid demands when the
person making the demands
of us isn't present, and harder
for us to carry through
demands when we have to look
face to face at the person we
are harming?
Well, what it is about human
beings is the unsurprising
fact that we are fundamentally,
deep down, and
profoundly social entities.
And we're social entities in a
way that is continuous with
our non-human primate
ancestors.
So Harry Harlow, in the first
half of the century, conducted
a number of studies using
non-human primates to try to
figure out what role emotional
connection and social bonding
played in allowing
them to flourish.
So in the famous wire
versus cloth
mother studies, monkeys--
there's a little one
right there--
were presented with two beings,
wire beings with whom
they could spend their time.
The wire mother had milk, and
they needed to go to her to
get food, but the cloth mother
had comfort, and if they
wanted to be consoled, they
needed to go to her.
And monkey after monkey after
monkey did what you see in
this picture.
Went--
and the fact that you're saying
"aw" is evidence of the
point that I'm making.
So we think this is adorable.
We think--
in fact, it's very hard to
control your facial muscles
when you look at that picture.
Right?
All of us are looking at it,
seeing these big warm eyes,
and this expression
of affection.
It is part of the primate
maturation experience that in
order to become a healthy and
flourishing member of the
species, early social
contact is crucial.
And indeed, some of Harlow's
more morally problematic
studies involved subjecting
young monkeys to complete
social deprivation, and
discovering afterwards that
when they came out of that
deprivation, their behavior
was incompatible with living
in a community.
Not only were they hostile and
aggressive towards their
peers, even with respect to the
children that they had,
they were incapable of engaging
in nurturing.
So one might wonder, as Harlow's
student John Bowlby
and his collaborator, Mary
Ainsworth, did, whether
there's anything that can be
said about what's required for
human beings to flourish that
can be learned from the
picture that we see
in the Harlow wire
baby cloth baby studies.
That is, is it possible that for
human beings to thrive, we
need a certain sort of warmth
and interaction that isn't
limited merely to the receipt
of nutrients required for
maturation from a wire mother?
So I take this next slide,
this next chart, from a
website called "Positive
Parenting," because I want you
to recognize how much the
picture that Bowlby and
Ainsworth have advanced has
permeated contemporary
conceptions of how it is that
it's appropriate to parent
one's children.
So famously, Mary Ainsworth
brought young children,
roughly two years old, into a
laboratory setting along with
their primary caregiver.
And the question she wanted to
see was, how comfortable were
the children in what was known
as a strange situation, a
situation in which they would
be required to set out on
their own, away from their
caregiver, in order to engage
with some appealing toys.
And on the basis of that, that
she identified three--
it's now been expanded
to four--
three styles of attachment that
children might have to
their caregivers.
The first, which she called
secure attachment, results
from early childhood experience
that involves
predictable responsiveness to
one's needs by somebody who
feels affection for you.
If you are hungry, somebody
responds by
providing you with food.
If you are sore, somebody
responds by
comforting your pain.
If you are cold, somebody
responds by warming you up.
And all of this is done in such
a way that you begin to
form an impression of yourself
as an agent in the world whose
expression of needs and desires
can evince in other
conscious beings responses that
reflect what it is that
you need and desire.
The world becomes a place
in which social trust is
possible, and the early
instincts that you come to
have, when presented with
the faces and bodies of
conspecifics, cause you, later
on, to have as your most
primitive response pattern an
expectation that, if there's
no evidence to the contrary,
that conspecific is going to
be responsive to your honest
and expressed needs.
By contrast, a smaller
percentage of the children
exhibited what Ainsworth called
avoidant attachment.
They were unwilling to explore
the room, and they were
unwilling to do so, hypothesized
Ainsworth,
because their early childhood
experience had been one with a
disengaged or distant
caregiver.
Upon expression of need, there
was no sense that if there's a
social other, that social other
will respond to what it
is that you are asking for.
So there's a sense that
developed that the world is
not a safe and cooperative
place.
The third group were children
that she called
ambivalently attached.
Ambivalently attached children
experienced a regimen of
response which was sometimes
in keeping with what they
asked, and sometimes ignoring
them entirely.
So although they didn't have the
sense that the world never
does what you ask it too, they
did have the sense that the
world doesn't reliably do
what you ask it to.
And finally, into a fourth
category added subsequently,
fall children who are not merely
ignored, but who are in
fact abused or mistreated
in the face of
expression of need.
Now, this taxonomy is not of a
level of precision that it
will tell you easily for every
child into which category they
fall as a result of
their treatment.
There are lots of issues about
innate dispositions that
children have, and there are
lots of cases where it might
not be clear how to put children
into this taxonomy.
Nonetheless, it has served as
the basis for one of the most
extraordinary scientific studies
conducted in the last
century, which is a thirty
year longitudinal study
conducted by people who took
attachment theory seriously,
who looked at the extent to
which predictors of subsequent
flourishing could be traced to
early childhood experience.
And this book, The Development
of the Person (which I read
over the summer) is
extraordinary in the sense
that it shows what it takes to
establish a complicated social
scientific hypothesis
with even a
reasonable degree of certainty.
Because of course, if you want
to find out about whether
early childhood experience
affects subsequent
development, we can't use
you guys, because we
lost our time machine.
We left it in the future.
So we can't go back and
look at what your
childhoods were like.
All of these studies needed
to be done perspectively.
So what this group did was to
study hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of children, with
incredible effort to follow
them even when they
moved away.
And the basic conclusion
that they draw--
the book is several hundred
pages long, but the basic
conclusion that they draw
confirms the thesis that
attachment theory
hypothesizes.
That early childhood experience,
and particularly
early childhood experience of
a trusting and responsive
relationship, significantly
shapes later patterns of
response to the world.
But of course, we've
heard that before.
We heard it when we were told
that "it's not unimportant to
acquire one sort of habit or
another right from youth.
It is, in fact, all-important."
Now, none of this is to say
that those whose early
childhood experiences were
not optimal will
never flourish or thrive.
The human spirit is remarkably
resilient, and it is possible,
through certain kinds of
therapeutic interaction, or
certain kinds of cultivation of
other trusting relations,
to overcome early childhood
deprivation.
But there is an easier path to
flourishing, and that is the
one that goes through trusting
early childhood.
Now, the fact that human beings
are social beings
affects us not just at the
beginning of the lifespan, but
also at the end.
"If you want to predict," points
out Jonathan Haidt,
"how happy someone is, or how
long they're likely to live,
you should find out about their
social relationships.
Having strong social
relationships strengthens the
immune system.
It extends life more than
quitting smoking.
It speeds recovery from surgery,
reduces the risk of
depression and anxiety
disorders." Social
interactions are crucial
to human flourishing.
And this is not just something
that we discover in the west.
Here are some titles of articles
that I pulled out of
Google Scholar when
I was doing my
directed exercise three.
"Effects of Social Integration:
On Preserving
Memory Function in a U.S.
Elderly Population." Here's
one about ten-year survival rate
in an Australian society.
Here's one about social
integration and
mortality in France.
Here's one about social
interaction and
mortality in Sweden.
Here's one in Finland.
Here's one in Japan.
Here's one in China.
In every culture which anybody
has looked at, social
engagement is crucial to
human flourishing.
Now, we might want ask whether
this tells us anything about
the question that we're
concerned within this segment
of the course--the question of
human flourishing--and whether
this tells us anything about the
questions that we're going
to address in the subsequent
units of the course.
Our discussions of morality
and our discussions of
political philosophy.
So Harrow and Bowlby and the
Minnesota study have pointed
out that in order for human
beings to develop the kind of
trusting relationship that
enables a society even to get
off the ground, it's crucial
that there be a certain sort
of stable social connection
in infancy.
We'll ask, in the context of
our discussion of political
philosophy, whether this has
any implications for how a
society needs to be structured
if we hope to cultivate in it
just citizens capable of
domestic and democratic
participation.
Does it mean, astoundingly, that
something we might think
would be of no concern as far as
political philosophy goes,
the internal structure of the
family, is of concern, as far
as political philosophy goes?
And if so, does that turn out to
be a victory for the left?
For the right?
Or something else altogether?
We'll ask in the context of
Haidt's discussion of romantic
love as an extraordinary
combination, as you read, of
our capacity for attachment, our
capacity for caregiving,
and our capacity for mating,
whether any moral code we have
needs to respect the fact that
we will have special
relationships to certain
individuals that will render
us incapable of treating them as
one among many, even though
what morality seems to demand
of us is that we treat
everybody equally.
We'll ask, in the context of
Nozick's discussion in the
paper that we read of love as
a formation of a we, whether
when we form connections that
extend beyond individuals
connections to things like
neighborhoods or religious
communities or nations, whether
that itself has any
moral or political bearing.
We'll turn back to the question
raised by James
Stockdale who pointed out
to us the importance of
friendship, of unit cohesion,
and of close camaraderie in
permitting resilience in the
face of suffering, whether
it's in fact incumbent upon
political structures to
promote stability in communities
so as to allow
people to whether the storms
that fortune brings.
And in so doing, we'll be able
to make sense of this
extraordinarily strange
phenomenon, which is that
Aristotle's Nicomachean Ethics,
a book about ethics
that grounds the Western ethical
tradition, includes
within its twelve chapters two
full chapters devoted to the
question of friendship, in
which Aristotle begins by
pointing out that if you are
young or if you are old, if
you are rich, if you are poor,
if you are at a time of your
life when things are going well
or if you're at a time of
your life where things are going
badly, nothing plays a
more central role in allowing
you to flourish than
friendship does.
Thanks to all of you
for coming by
for an extra lecture.
I'm happy to take questions,
though technically we've come
to the end of the fifty minutes
that we were allotted.
But I'm happy to answer
questions,
because there's no deadline.
Hello, yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, people can go!
Ask your question.
I'd love to answer it.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
between early childhood
nurturing, which leads to
flourishing, and neglect,
which would lead
to something bad.
But that seems to be kind of
morally-charged, there's a
value judgment inherent
in all of this.
And I've been wondering because
I think that book that
you mentioned about different
facets of our personality
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
experience because we can't say
that necessarily there's a
good way to know how to
raise your child.
PROFESSOR: OK so the question
was, look, I made a statement
that a certain kind of early
childhood nurturing seems to
lead to social capabilities of
a certain kind, whereas early
childhood neglect seems to lead
to social disabilities.
In making that statement, A, I
making a value judgment that's
illegitimate about how we want
to be able to function in
society, B, am I making a
value judgment that's
illegitimate about what's
appropriate in child rearing?
So let me turn to the second
first. The claims about early
childhood nurturing that are
made here are primarily about
roughly the first eighteen
months of life.
There is great dispute here on
campus and elsewhere about
what is appropriate after those
first eighteen months.
But there seems to be pretty
clear evidence, both
domestically and
cross-culturally, that during
the first eighteen months, the
idea of too much nurturing,
too much responsiveness,
is one on which it's
hard to get a handle.
That is, being such that your
needs are responded to seems
to be a way of promoting
stability and trust. OK.
Back to your first question.
Are we making value judgments
about what it's like to be a
good person when we say: we're
looking to cultivate in
ourselves the possibility of
trust and connection instead
of a life of distrust?
I suppose there are
circumstances, societies in
which being trusting would
be a detriment.
Being able to respond to
somebody without constantly
being on guard would
be dangerous.
And in those circumstances, it
would perhaps make sense to
cultivate a different kind of
early childhood experience.
Whether that shows that we've
found two equally good forms
of flourishing is something
we'll talk about when we talk
about moral relativism
in a few weeks.
Good.
Thanks.